hello everyone and welcome to the
coolest four move game you will ever see
ah here it goes Pawn to D4 by white and
Knight to F6 by black and here white
plays Knight to D2 it's a really weird
move to play but who are we to judge and
here black plays Ponte E5 as the D4 Pawn
is undefended black wants to capture
here so white captures on E5 and the
black plays Knights the G4 and here why
it says alright I don't want any of this
tricky business I'm just gonna play H3
give back the pawn and you know have a
happy life but black says not so fast
black plays Knights to E3 and here white
resigns the game as the White Queen is
now trapped you either give up the queen
or you have to capture the Knight and
then you get checkmated Queen H4 check
G3 and queen captures and G3 is
Checkmate so there we have it after
Knight E3 white resigns and is this not
the coolest four move game you have ever
seen see you soon